G
GOALTENDER, WHAT A LEADER HE WAS
KEMPE'S SHOT TIPPED AWAY.
RANGERS ARE GOODROW AND KOPITAR.
FOX IS THERE.
MOVES IT UP THE  FOR L.A.
>> Joe: KOPITAR TRIED TO USE
ADAM FOX.
HE LOOKS.
IN FRONTS SCORE!ICE.
WATCH HIM GO TO WORKFIVE-MINUTE
BOARDING.
STROME GETSPLAY.
RANGERS REALLY MOVED IT NGERS R.
MILLER FORIT.
A NICE PASSING PLAY BUT ALEAFS.
THAT IS BROKEN UP BY ANDERSON.
LIZOTTE IS GOING TO USE THE
DEFENSEMAN JACOB TROEIDER STOPP
FEW OTHER ME.
KREIDER IS IN THE CIRCLE.
FOX MOVES IN!AT.
PANARIN MOVES IN.
MIKEY ANDERSON IS THERE AND
PANARIN SCORES!
IAFALLO SCORES!N.
STROME.
UP THE BOARDS TO PANARIN.
IN FRONT!
POWER-PLAY GOAL AND GAVE THE T.
SCORE! DOES IT AND BARCLAY
GOODROW
ZIBANEJAD SHOOTS.
PANARIN AND FOX ON A
FOUR-ON-THREE POWER PLAY
ADVANT LINDGREN.
KINGS ZONE.
MOVED UP AHEAD.E.S THIS
SEASON.
HERE WENG.
>> Sam: HUGE
>> Joe: H H TWO. ZIBANEJAD.
>> Joe: LET'S SEE IF HE DOES HIE
WOW.
>> Joe: WHAT A
SWINGS THAT TAKE?
UP IN FOR
THE RANGERS.
RYAN STROME
QUINTON-BY-FIELD INNG ON!
KEEP FINDING A WAY TO KEEP
FOX AGAINST QUICK.